[Applause]
[Music]
today we are going to talk about the
topic you've all been waiting for public
spending in the european union following
the coronavirus
[Applause]
[Music]
wait wait wait don't leave us just let
okay don't fall asleep
[Music]
i know that talking about the general
budget of the european union sounds like
the most boring topic on the planet but
we're talking about one of the largest
public spending operations in history
over a period of more than seven years
europe is going to spend more than two
trillion euros and yes i said trillions
with a capital t where will all this
money come from well if you're watching
this video from any eu country it will
come directly from you and probably if
you live outside the european union too
why we'll look at that a bit later but
what is certain is that we are talking
about one of the most important issues
of this era an issue that is going to
have profound consequences in our lives
in other words it may seem boring but
believe me you should pay attention to
it so the questions we are wondering
today are why does the european union
want to spend so much money precisely at
this time where will this money go is
that a good idea or are we perhaps
facing a new era of what could be called
crony capitalism in this video we're
going to tell you
[Applause]
the keynesian formula
[Music]
i know what you're all wondering why
does the european union want to bring
out so many spending programs in this
precise time actually the european union
is not alone in this the united states
has also said that it is going to
increase public spending and many other
countries are planning to do the same so
why you may ask okay we're in a unique
situation we just went through an entire
pandemic that has left the economy
trembling actually we're not even sure
we're done with the coronavirus pandemic
but what does an economic crisis have to
do with increasing public spending the
answer lies with this man you see in the
photo
meet john maynard keynes one of the most
influential economists in history we
could say that lord keynes was the
father of modern social democracy
although in reality his economic
doctrine has influenced parties right
across the political spectrum it has
influenced and continues to influence
proof of this is that although he died
in 1945 today we are still applying his
formulas almost to the letter
[Music]
and what did this feinman propose well
keynes understood that the economy is a
wheel that cannot be stopped in his
opinion economic crises are bad because
citizens stop consuming and that slows
down the activity the best way out of a
crisis is keep the party going
reactivate consumption by any means
necessary if private companies and
citizens can no longer consume then
ideally the state should do it after all
the state can always go into debt raise
taxes or even print its own money of
course all these decisions have
consequences but by proxy it can so
keynesian theory says roughly that in
times of recession the state has to
spend but spending will generate new
jobs which in turn translates into
people with money in their pockets to
buy things from private companies
suddenly the money starts moving again
and the economy is lifted out of the
doldrums
but not only that private companies
invest money in what is profitable and
that does not always benefit the common
good however the state can decide to
spend on things that are good for
everyone science innovation public
services who could be against this in
principle keynesian formulas could seem
to be the final solution to all major
economic problems neither communism nor
free markets kenyanism the perfect
marriage between business and state
right as you can imagine there is a
problem and for us to understand it
better let's examine it with an example
spain back in 2009
spain was one of the country's hardest
hit by the 2008 financial crisis in less
than two years the unemployment rate
doubled and during those hard times the
then prime minister jose luis rodriguez
zapatero made the most important
announcement of his career
[Music]
yes visualpolitik fans we are talking
about the famous plan e in a few years
spain spent between 12 and 50 billion
euros and yes i know the range is very
large but even today it is difficult to
calculate what the total amount of this
plan actually was and you will say is
that a lot of money for spain well as a
comparison spain collected taxes in that
same year 2009 totaling 198 billion
euros that is yes suddenly spain was
spending money like there was no
tomorrow and now you'll see but is it
that simple suddenly the government
started spending the money just like
that just just for the sake of it
[Music]
as ridiculous as it sounds yes basically
during the years of plan e all spanish
cities repaved their streets renewed
their urban furniture and put a statue
on every roundabout remember that there
was no concrete objective it was not a
plan to renovate hospitals because
they'd become obsolete nor was an
attempt to improve i don't know
infrastructure in general no the
objective was to generate spending to
create jobs to resuscitate the economy
so any project no matter how ridiculous
was eligible for funding here's an
example
the public spa in the capital has been
closed for a year and a half the
facility built with funds from plan e
and with a budget of 959 000 euros was
never opened and i know what many of you
are thinking what's the problem here
okay a city council could spend almost 1
million euros to build a spa that nobody
ends up using but what does it matter if
the state can borrow to infinity and
beyond well yes it's true states can
borrow more money than families or
companies all this is true up to a point
[Music]
spain issued debt bonds like there was
no tomorrow meanwhile the spanish media
were too busy discussing whatever they
decided were the hot topics at the
moment but the international investors
those who were lending money to spain
were less and less confident that the
spanish state could pay back what it had
borrowed and what happens when investors
don't trust you well this happens
moody's cut spain to one notch above
junk in other words spain owed so much
money that it was difficult to pay it
back and since no one trusted spain
investor demanded higher interest rates
to compensate for that risk to give you
an idea there were years when interest
payments alone accounted for the second
largest item of expenditure in all
budgets and then the media stopped
worrying about the trivial problems and
began to consider the extent to which
spain was bankrupt believe me when i
tell you that you don't want to live
through a similar crisis
[Laughter]
and i know what many of you are thinking
grant you have given us a very specific
example spain is an example of poorly
executed public spending probably
spanish politicians are corrupt or
simply did not consult the right experts
but in this video we're talking about
the european union in this case public
spending is going to be overseen by the
brightest minds in europe people who
know exactly where and how to spend
those 2 trillion euros efficiently it's
not spending for spending's sake right
well we're going to look at that now
[Music]
europe's helicopter money
before we continue we have to make a
small note the budgets of the european
union are approved for the next seven
years in other words the budgets that
have been approved to cover the period
from 2021 to 2027. the budgets that have
just been approved can be divided into
three items the ordinary budget which
amounts to 1.1 trillion euros then we
have the sure mechanism which is where
aid is given to businesses that have
suffered the most during lockdowns
finally there is the mother of all
public spending the next generation eu
this item accounts for
750 billion euros and this is the
european union's big gamble the idea
behind this spending program is to make
europe the greenest most digital
holistic and 2.0 place in the world and
that translates into what we could call
the great european fire hose the largest
spending program in the history of the
european union more than 2 trillion
euros will be spent over the next 7
years and yes we are talking about
trillions
[Music]
to put it in perspective this amount is
almost seven times what the total
bailout of the greek economy costs and
it has just been approved with almost no
one putting up the slightest debate so
how is all this going to be paid for
well i think you can already imagine the
answer
european parliament votes for new taxes
in eu to repay recovery borrowing and
now i know what many of you are thinking
is it really enough to create new taxes
to finance all this spending obviously
not europe needs cash and it needs it
now so what does states do when they
need money fast well i think you can
probably guess the answer to that as
well
eu issues the largest single trunch bond
to fund postcovid recovery the european
union sends a strong message with its
inaugural next generation eu bond to
support a green digital and responsible
recovery that's right suddenly what was
once a taboo subject in the european
union is now a reality eurobonds and why
were eurobonds a taboo subject in the
european union we created a video on
this topic on visualpolitik a year ago
you'll find the link in the description
but in short the problem with euro bonds
is that they relieve member states of
the responsibility of paying debts in
other words countries with low credit
ratings like spain or greece rely on the
more reliable countries in europe like
germany or the netherlands all this
might be a good idea if european budgets
were implemented from brussels but the
reality is very different in truth the
european union only provides the money
it is the member states to decide where
it is spent so how is this money being
distributed is it divided equally is it
allocated according to population
tendency not at all look at this graph
here you can see how spain is the
undisputed winner in these budgets it
gets more than 15 of the entire european
funding and no most of this money is not
going to be managed from brussels but
from madrid the way this works is as
follows the member countries in this
case spain present a spending plan to
brussels brussels approves it and pays
all the bills in other words national
politicians can take the medal for
spending money hand over fist while
leaving the burden of debt and taxes to
be carried by europe
[Music]
now i know what many of you are thinking
it cannot be that simple we are talking
about the european union the place where
the brightest minds in world politics
come together surely there are a lot of
controls to prevent money from ending up
where it shouldn't be right surely
brussels is not going to allow a failure
like spain's disastrous plan e well
you're partly right the european union
wants to ensure that all member
countries have the rule of law and
anti-corruption mechanisms and that
explains news stories like this one
the european commission is ready to
approve poland's recovery plan as soon
as november if warsaw will agree to
certain legally binding objectives to
restore the rule of law in other words
the european union has come to poland
and said i will not give you your share
of the money if you are not prepared to
guarantee that it will not end up in the
hands of the government's friends many
of you may think that this is the
definitive proof that in brussels they
know how to spend public money but the
question is are these control mechanisms
really enough well we're going to look
at that right now and we're going to see
it with the country that is set to
receive the most money from these
budgets check this out
spain is different or perhaps not
as we've said spain is the biggest
beneficiary of these european budgets
and it was also one of the first
countries to present its spending plan
the spain conduit plan outlines how the
spanish government is going to spend
more than 140 billion euros that will
come from europe you can check out on
their website which i'll link for you in
the description at the time of making
this video you could only see a couple
of spending projects what about the rest
well that's the fun part because we
don't know in other words the european
union has approved spain's spending plan
without it having been made public yes
this in itself is a lack of transparency
and a golden opportunity for big
consulting firms like kpmg listen up
kpmg revolutionizes consultancy on
european funds kpmg in spain and local
europe have signed an alliance to offer
a comprehensive solution of consultancy
services on european funds together with
an exclusive technological tool that
facilitates the identification of
specific projects that may be eligible
for access to aid that's right the big
consulting firms have already started to
advise on how to get their hands on the
european firehose and who can afford to
enlist kpmg's services believe me we are
talking about expensive services
services that are only available to
large companies but wait because you
haven't seen anything yet
[Music]
among the projects that have been made
public there are two particularly
striking ones one is the rehabilitation
of public buildings that is if plan e
served to pave all the streets of spain
the plan e you will serve to
rehabilitate public buildings something
that as everyone knows is fundamental to
the fight against climate change and
economic transformation right but wait
because there is still more another of
the plans that spain has proposed is
the creation of an audiovisual hub that
is spain is going to spend a whopping
200 million euros in subsidies to make
tv series and video games and because
these days everything has to be
environmentally friendly digital
holistic and 2.0 this project includes
gems like this one
the commission will work on a best
practice guide for green production and
service provision the approach will be
gradual with the aim of raising
awareness and pushing the industry to
start implementing more sustainable
solutions how can films be produced in
an environmentally friendly and
sustainable way well
i don't know but there is a whole report
on how to greenify audio visual
production
[Music]
at this point many of you may be asking
yourselves but who came up with this
project to what extent does the
production of series and video games
serve this green digital holistic and
2.0 transformation that europe needs so
much well those of you watching this
video from spain can already guess who
is behind all this
media pro is looking for a multi-million
investment for its own audio visual hub
according to expansion the group has
started to search for capital about 500
million euros to create a new audio
visual hub in spain for those of you who
don't know media pro it is a film and
television production company with
well-known ties to the political parties
that are now in the spanish government
its president is this gentleman you see
on the screen whose name is yao mei
raures media pro is on the verge of
bankruptcy in fact they have asked
several times for a government bailout
in other words it could be said that
this audiovisual hub of europe project
has a name and a surname and pay
attention because that is not the only
example check this out
[Music]
a judge unblocks the rescue of plus
ultra by not appreciating for now any
crime the airline will receive the 34
million euros it has pending to continue
operating in this case we are talking
about the rescue of an airline that
operates four flights a week virtually
no one knew of this existence until
months ago the owners of this airline
also have certain connections with some
members of the government so spain of
course has not hesitated for a moment to
bail them out of course the bailout may
be perfectly legal after all in times of
the coronavirus many other companies
have been rescued the question is is
this really a strategic company that
needed to be rescued if plus ultra is
rescued why shouldn't any other company
be rescued and you will say but hang on
it can't be that simple surely someone
in brussels is responsible for ensuring
that there is no corruption or cronyism
when it comes to spending the money and
yes you are right there is a european
body in charge of controlling public
money the anti-corruption prosecutor's
office the problem is that they are
overwhelmed
[Music]
think of it this way more public
spending means more projects to research
according to an estimate by the european
commission we are talking about a
workload nine times greater than normal
however the number of researchers has
barely increased in other words europe
is going to spend a lot of money on a
lot of things except hiring people to
control or monitor the spending so now
the question is over to you is this
european firehose really going to make
europe more green sustainable digital
holistic and 2.0 or are we facing a new
era of corona capitalism what impact is
all this going to have on our pocket
will we see a new debt crisis again you
can leave us your answer in the comments
below as always don't forget that here
on visualpolitik we release new videos
every week so subscribe to this channel
and hit the little bell button down
there so you don't miss any of our
updates if you like this video like it
so we find out and i'll see you next
time
[Music]
you